at this point it should be abundantly
clear to anybody paying even the
slightest bit of attention to the U.S
Mexico border that the border is not
open the border is it's just not open
there's there's no nothing you can point
to there's no statistic there's no
policy you can point to to prove the
case that the border is open under Joe
Biden and so what did former Republican
governor of Alaska former Republican
vice presidential candidate former
Congressional candidate failed by the
way Sarah Palin say when she went on
Newsmax she said the border is open
we're going to check this out this is
another one of these examples of Sarah
Palin in her echoey room visibly
struggling to use language to
communicate anything of meaning
uh in this particular case speaking to
newsmax's Eric bowling about the topic
of immigration and this is an important
issue because the lies that the right is
telling about immigration are uh uh
sticking with some voters let's listen
then we'll discuss a country that puts
the needs in private priorities of
Invaders over those who fought for it
well that sounds to me like Joe Biden's
America New York is booting homeless
veterans removing them from New York
hotels in order to put illegal migrants
into those hotels and why because these
Sanctuary cities can't handle what they
decided to take on let's bring in former
Alaska Governor Sarah Palin to weigh in
Governor you know an expert on
immigration let's bring in Sarah Palin
this they asked for it they begged for
it we give it to them and they want to
push back now and they're going to move
out veterans who are having a tough time
in favor of
illegal aliens coming in your thoughts
right I mean the whole open borders
issue is bad enough and I sit on the
cake now though is that our veterans
again are being kicked to the curb okay
we're going to go back to it but let's
pause it there the open border thing is
bad enough
can anyone tell me in what way the
border is open and I really want to know
I'm I'm I looked and I said okay let's
look at all changes at the border from
Trump to Biden and I can't find any way
in which that border is open the Biden
Administration has repeatedly said the
border is closed just like Trump did
they have said people should not attempt
to cross illegally just like Trump did
the administration sent troops to the
Border increased surveillance increased
technology at the border worked with
Mexico to deter migration to the United
States and importantly since title 42
expired the number of people encountered
trying to cross has decreased despite
the fear-mongering by Republicans I was
unable to find a single way in which the
border is open it is true that the Biden
Administration is respecting the process
when people come to the border and ask
for Asylum that is the law that is the
law and it is not a change in policy
it's possible that the Trump
Administration was ignoring the law
but I can't find any way in which the
border is open so if somebody knows
please tell me let's continue here with
Sarah Palin literally as illegal aliens
are being given precedence over this now
there are two issues one is the the
veterans issue and uh it just makes me
sick to my stomach and it makes me sick
to know that our leaders in government
are not giving our vets their due we're
we're not providing them uh the benefits
the promises and and that affects you
know every aspect of most every
Veteran's life this is particularly
disgusting because this is the same
Sarah Palin who in 2008 when she was
running alongside the late Senator John
McCain to be president for him to be
president and for her to be Vice
President of the United States
she defended the bush decision to go
into Iraq which of course led to
thousands of American troop deaths and
subsequently tens of thousands hundreds
of thousands of injuries and
psychological trauma which then these
very same Republicans were not
interested in properly funding the VA
and benefits for veterans and now she
has the audacity to say oh Biden doesn't
care about veterans oh okay but also
though the open murders
in skull
of treason and if it's if this isn't
treason when you consider what our
leaders are doing in their aiding and
abetting illegal at least and they're
they're putting our safety the security
of our nation ultimately our sovereignty
at risk we are being destroyed by the
left's open borders policies all right
that I think we've probably had enough
find me some way in which the border is
open and I will report it tomorrow if
anybody can let me know